NIC Robertson ، لقد كنت داخل ذلك
المؤتمر الصحفي الذي سمعناه أنك تسأل
هذا السؤال الأول ، هل أنت تشير
بإصبع اللوم بشكل فعال وأنا
أعيد صياغتك هنا في إيران
وتجاهل المتحدث هذا السؤال
إلى حد ما تحليلك لما
سمعته ولكن  بيكي فقط لتوسيع هذا الأمر
قليلاً بالطبع ليس فقط الصحفيين
في الغرفة ، ربما لم تكن قادرًا على
رؤيتهم خارج الكاميرا ولكن الكثير من
الدبلوماسيين هنا السفراء
الملحق العسكري بالفعل ثم هناك
الأشخاص الذين تراهم خلفي ليسوا صحفيين
إنهم سفراء دول مختلفة
مدعوون هنا حتى يتمكنوا من
الحصول على أعينهم على هذه المكونات ، سبع
طائرات بدون طيار ، صاروخان من صواريخ كروز تم
إطلاقهما بإجمالي 25 صاروخًا ، لكنني أعتقد أنه
كان من الواضح أن ما نسمعه
هنا هو عرض تقديمي
الأدلة العسكرية وهذا ما قالته
وزارة الدفاع أنهم سيفعلون
فعلوه لدرجة أنهم وضعوها في
المجال العام لأن الأسئلة التي كنت
أطرحها  حاول أن تسألك
سؤالًا من شأنه أن يشرح
للشخص العادي إذا كنت ستفهم لماذا يمكنك استخلاص
هذه الاستنتاجات حول مدى
هذه الصواريخ والطائرات بدون طيار
لكن المتحدث تراجع عما
هو شائع جدًا في الدوائر
العسكرية وفي  تحليل
أنظمة الأسلحة هذه هو أنها تُعرف
عمومًا بالأنظمة المصنعة للمصنع الإيراني ،
لذلك لا يوجد نوع من
الغموض حول هذا النطاق بالطبع
كان قائلًا إنه لا يمكن أن
يأتي من اليمن ، كنت مهتمًا بشكل خاص
عندما أحاول ذلك  أحاول
معرفة كيف يتراجعون باستخدام
أي دليل لمعرفة أين أطلقت
صواريخ كروز هذه ، ما مجموعه سبعة
صواريخ كروز ما مجموعه 18 طائرة بدون طيار تم إرسالها
في اتجاه هذه المنشآت
وكيف يحاولون التراجع
وأشار إلى  بالنسبة لأنظمة GPS داخل
الطائرات بدون طيار ، فإن الطائرات بدون طيار على وجه الخصوص
للإشارة إلى أنها تبحث في
البيانات الموجودة في نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي (GPS) لأن الأب
سيوفر سلسلة إذا كنت  مثل
فتات نقل البيانات إلى المكان الذي
أقلعت منه الطائرات بدون طيار ، ومن المثير للاهتمام
أنه قال حتى أثناء قيامهم بذلك ،
فإن الإيرانيين الذين قال إنهم يحاولون
التدخل في هذه العملية
ربما لم يذكر على وجه التحديد كيف
تم إغلاقها أو تنظيفها  البيانات الموجودة
على بعض أجهزة GPS
هذه مهمة ولكن من
الواضح جدًا أنه ظل بعيدًا عن كما
تعلم ، السؤال الكبير هنا هو أن هذا يحتوي على كل
السمات المميزة لإيران
التي أوضحها للتو إذا كانت إيران
هي نقطة الإطلاق أو على الرغم من
كونك مجرد بصمات لإيران ،
ما الذي ستفعله وقال: انظر إلى هذا
ليس قرارًا بالنسبة لي ،
إنه عمل يمثل قرارًا على المستوى السياسي ،
لكن من الواضح أن وظيفته كانت توفير
التحليل الأساسي لعملية
صنع القرار السياسي.  ومما تم
عرضه هنا بشكل لا لبس فيه بشكل لا لبس
فيه ، يبدو أنه يدعم ما قيل
أن هذه كانت معدات إيرانية الصنع.